the nun is the newest spin-off to the
conjuring universe following the
Annabelle films and this is actually
based around the demon that briefly
appeared in the conjuring two that
originally wasn't actually going to be
in the film but was later added and
ended up being one of the most iconic
scenes in the entire film and I was
actually looking forward to seeing this
film because not only do I like the
conjuring universe except for the first
Annabelle movie I was looking forward to
seeing this movie not just because I'm a
massive horror fan but because this
summer was kind of disappointing when it
came to movies there were a lot of films
I was looking forward to they ended up
just being okay so I was hoping that the
fall would have a nice start with the
nun and it's it it's a movie with noises
the central plot of the film is that we
have a young woman who has yet to make
her vows and a priest who are going to
Romania to investigate some evil
goings-on and the nun demon is there and
things pop out a lot that's that's the
nun man this movie could have been
really awesome and it frustrates me it's
one of those films that as I watched it
I kept seeing what it could have been
and they just didn't care to take it to
that level there are so many scenes
where someone looks through a hall weep
and to the hall what do you think's
gonna happen when we pan back to them of
course like it's just a bunch of
sequences like that there are no
frightening jump scares there's tons of
them but you can see them coming from a
mile away
beyond that I think the worst offense
that the nun has to it is that it feels
almost story less yes we have these
characters going to investigate some
evil stuff that's happening there's a
pretty cool opening scene but the film
feels so narrative lease light that I
just couldn't get invested in the
characters and since the nun is why most
of us are there to see this this demon
she's actually not in the film that much
and so that was also very disappointing
her appearances were highlights but
they're so few and far between that I'm
just waiting for random things to pop
out because that's all this film really
does there are so many scare scenes that
are entirely about the demon messing
with the main characters she locks the
priest underground somehow in a coffin
and he's trapped there for a while until
he has the means to communicate to the
other woman and she comes in and she's
like oh my god you're underground if
what is the goal here like why is the
demon locking him in a coffin
underground so we can have like this
claustrophobic sequence or is she
actually trying to kill the guy because
if she was trying to kill him then the
demon would find a way to remove the
Bell that he's pulling on a string
that's in the coffin that lets people
know he's buried down there there are so
many scenes that are just the demon
pulling really elaborate pranks and
that's what it comes off as as you watch
the film because they don't lead to
anything story-wise of course there's
the backstory that someone reads about
in a book in which we learned the
demon's name even though if we had seen
the other conjuring films we would have
heard it a few times before and it's
just it follows all of those cliches
we've seen a thousand times in these
films and it just it boggles my mind
that a film that could come from
something as good as the conjuring films
it's just this rote throwaway movie with
a demon that likes to play pranks all
the time similar to the first Annabelle
I found this film very underwhelming who
knows maybe they'll make a sequel to the
none like Annabelle creation and it'll
be a lot better
I don't know this movie is nowhere near
on the level of what Jane
Juan brought two the first two conjuring
films so I wouldn't go to it expecting
that if you just want to see a film with
some very dark and very blue visuals go
have fun I guess I'm gonna give the nun
a d-plus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching please look forward to more
reviews very soon as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]